[Music]
hi I'm Sam and this is Maurice
we're both leads on the I'm on the
sheets team I led the creation of the
sheets before API and Maurice led the
slides API and we're here to talk to you
today about using a Google Apps Script
and the G suite editors to make your
life easier
automate internal processes and really
just make things simpler and better for
you so we're gonna walk through some
demos today I'm gonna give sort of an
appetizer demo and then a longer run
through of a process that an HR person
might use to hire people and I'll let
Maurice talk about his demo when it
comes to him and our goal today is
really to show you how you can use Apps
Script and spend less money getting the
stuff you need to do done companies
spend billions of dollars a year
automating their workflows and that's
not even mentioning the time they spent
figuring out how to do it they have to
contact people to build it and work
through everything in order to get it
all done with Apps Script we can take a
lot of the pain away these are some
stories of some customers that have used
Apps Script to make their life better my
most favorite one by far is the very
last one where a company simplified a
horrible revision merge nightmare of
taking all these different files merging
them together and then creating some
kind of output and they simplified their
lives by using G suite to automate it
generating a PDF at the end and what
previously took about 40 hours a month
now takes under 3:00 and saves them and
they estimated over $100,000 a year and
a customer literally said this natural
quote finally I can take a vacation so
our goal here is for you to be able to
take a vacation from automating all of
these workflows so here's a simple
example of run likes parties right so
imagine that your throw
an office party and you want to send out
RSVPs you want to analyze who responds
to it what parts of the company they're
from are they from sales are they from
engineering book a venue based on the
results do you have enough people that
can fit in one do you need to split it
up into multiple venues what kinds of
places do people like to go to
traditionally this would be a lot of
manual labor
you'd have to pour through all the
results figure out how many people there
are where they belong in the company
maybe what office they're from where you
can host things or instead of doing that
you'd purchase some turnkey solution
which would cost a lot of money but
realistically office part of your
parties aren't all that important so
you'd probably just have some poor
person doing a the most minimal thing
possible and throwing a rather generic
party with app scripts and Docs editors
things are pretty easy you can create a
Google Form collect usernames when
sending out the forum get all your
results back and associate the form with
a sheet in forms itself you can analyze
all the responses you can see 66% of the
people said yes they're in 33% said no
they're not and in sheets it'll sync
right back up into sheets and you can
look and do sort of analysis and sheets
if you want to do it in a slightly
manual way maybe using sheets explore
asking questions of it but you can also
create an app script associated with the
sheet in order to do things for you so
here's a pretty 20 line example of how
you could create a very straightforward
app script that looks at all of your
data in the sheet and figures out who's
in sales who's in engineering so I'll go
through each line and sort of explain
what's happening here so at the top we
use the group's app and we get the
engine my company org and the sales of
my company or groups and then we get the
active spreadsheet because the script is
associated with a spreadsheet and we get
the data from that spreadsheet up until
the last row of data and we start the
engineering and sales counts at zero and
then loop through all of our data and we
say is this user in engineering by
asking is the N troop does the send
group have this users email address if
not are they in the sales group does it
have that users email address and we
just increment the sale
and the engineering variables by one and
then at the very end after we've
collected all of that we go back to the
spreadsheet and we get the sheet name
with results and we get arranged where
we want to put the data in and we say
this is how many people were Ange this
is how many people were in sales and so
this is a very sort of straightforward
example of how you can use Apps Script
just analyzing your data in sheets
automatically associating it with groups
and putting your data back in the sheet
so all of this code is JavaScript it's
all stored in the cloud with revision
history so if you make a mistake you can
go back in time and fix it and it's it's
hosted and run in the cloud too so you
don't have to spin up any jobs have
maintenance deal with having all of your
servers running fit seeing if anything
goes wrong with them and it's all secure
and it comes with G sweet but automating
parties isn't what brought you here
businesses have a lot more critical
tasks like hiring people there are a lot
of steps to hiring someone you have to
send offer letters you have to collect
employee information you have to have
them sign NDA's and verify their
employment history and so on and so
forth so I'm gonna walk through a demo
of how you could automate the process of
hiring someone if you can switch to the
demo machine here's a spreadsheet and I
filled it in with some basic examples
here of a employee name salary manager
name the team and whether or not an
offer letter was sent the offer letter
URL if they signed an NDA and so on and
so forth there's an extra column in here
for their email address which I've kept
hidden cuz I'm going to right now
actually make this a sort of an
interactive demo if you'd like to you
can see that there's a URL here gouda GL
capital P DW capital e QT and if you
want you can go to this place and fill
it out just remember it's all being
recorded and you can fill out a fake
name if you want to go into the employee
tracking thing so the the idea here is
that let's say there is an HR manager
and they have this spreadsheet with
their data and a form for new hires and
they want to send this out to hiring
managers and say is there anyone that
you want to hire if so fill out their
email address their name their salary
their manager
you can look what the form looks like
from the the managers perspective and
it's just here you see a little form or
they can type the stuff in and submit
the results others oates go to Google
Forms and the form is synced up with the
spreadsheet so the results come into the
spreadsheet
at this point you can click on this
workflows which is this custom menu item
that we added with Apps Script and click
send new offer letters what that's going
to do is iterate through the spreadsheet
similar to how we did the party example
and create a customized Google Doc for
the employee of their offer letter and
then email it to them with the link to
their customized Google Doc I afterwards
it's the the it'll mail that to the the
employee and the employee will basically
see in their email the link to their doc
and be able to click on it and so I'll
show you what that looks like so here's
one user it says you're hired Dear John
Doe congratulations you're hired
please view your offer letter which
includes the next steps at this URL
you open the URL and you see this
customized Google Doc for John Doe and
it has their salary their name the title
is specific for John Doe and it has to
continue the process please fill out
this NDA so we click on this link this
this NDA is hosted by Apps Script Apps
Script is acting as a web app in this
scenario and here's where it goes so it
says here's an NDA click here to sign it
when you sign it it comes back and says
thanks for signing the NDA and that was
also hosted by Apps Script and you can
see that the Apps Script then filled in
that yes the NDA was signed by John Doe
and none of the others yet have filled
it out and if for example I I see some
new people filled out the workflow or
the the form so if you click send new
offer letters again it'll figure out who
hasn't had an offer letter sent and send
new offer letters to each of these
people and update with the yes and the
customized
Google Doc for each of them so I'm gonna
walk through the code that makes this
possible so there's a script editor
associated with every sheet and when you
open up the script editor you see the
the code which runs it all and there's a
bunch of functions in here add menu
items and new offer letters and I'll
walk through each one in turn so add
menu items is the first one and this is
how the the workflows menu item got
added into your spreadsheet every Google
Doc or I'm sorry every Apps Script has
this current project triggers you can
edit triggers with your app script and
here I'm saying when I want to run the
add menu items function when there's an
event from a spreadsheet on open so
whenever anyone opens the spreadsheet it
will run this arbitrary function that I
made and run this code and what this
code is saying is give me the UI this
the spreadsheet app UI and create a menu
in the UI the workflows menu and in that
workflows menu I want to add an item
whose text is send new offer letters and
when someone clicks send new offer
letters it will run this function send
new offer letters and then I want to add
it to the UI so send new offer letters
what does that do in send to offer
letters we get the active spreadsheet
because this sheet is run from or the
script is run from a spreadsheet when
they clicked the the button in the UI it
there's an Associated spreadsheet you
can get it and then pop up in that
spreadsheet a toast saying sending offer
letters then we get the active sheet
which is the employee tracking sheet and
the last row which is the last row of
data in the spreadsheet we get the range
of all of the data that we care about
the start row from the start row and
column to the number of rows which is
the last row minus 1 and the number of
columns with the data we care about then
we get the display values of each of
these things which is how they are
presented in the UI itself then we
iterate through each of the bits of data
and get the data for each row the row
number the the name the email salary
manager team whether or not the offer
was sent and if the offer sent is not
yet
which is how I was able to click it
again and only send new offer letters if
they haven't said yes didn't offer a
cent then we create an offer letter and
I'll go through that function in a
moment so after we create the offer
letter it gives us the the ID of what
document was created for the offer
letter and we create this URL
docs.google.com document offer ID and
then a message that we're gonna email
dear so-and-so congratulations you're
hired please view your offer letter
which includes the next steps at your
offer URL sincerely HR it's a very
customized message so then we use Mail
app which is one of the other apps that
sort of built into Apps Script there's
many that exist and Maurice is gonna go
through a few more but mail app is one
that you can just send mail so you say
mail app send email with message the
email is the users email address the
subject of your hired the message and
just a little token saying we don't want
people to reply to this and then we get
the range in the spreadsheet saying yes
we did send an offer and here's the URL
of your customized offer letter when you
increment the amount of letters we sent
flush all of the changes out to the
spreadsheet so it puts it in the
spreadsheet and then pop up a toast
saying either you sent this many letters
or you didn't send any at all because
there was no new letters to send so how
did we create the offer letter so we
have a customized Google Doc which is
the template of the offer letter and in
this template we basically say welcome
to the next demo company hello name
we're thrilled to offer you a job your
starting salary will be salary you just
basically a spreadsheet or I'm sorry a
doc with tokens that we're gonna replace
with customization so in the script we
using our drive app this time we get the
file of our the ID with the ID of our
template and then make a copy of it on
the copy we then change the sharing and
we say this copy can be visible to
anyone who is the link but all they can
do is view it and then we change the
name of that file to say offer letter
for so-and-so then we use document app
which is the hook into Google Docs
within Apps Script and we get the doc by
document app
and get the body of the document and
then just do a bunch of replacements we
say for your name put the person's name
for their salary for the person's salary
manager team for the NDA it's a little
more complex because we wanted to do
text and URL so we get the the starting
point of where we want to replace text
and generate a URL and then say on this
this portion within the document set the
URL to this NDA URL using this other
function that I'll go through in a
moment generate NDA URL and then we
return the offer files ID so that the
email that we generated can link to it
so how do we generate the NDA URL
because if you remember that was served
I mentioned by Apps Script hosting as a
web app in this scenario so generate NDA
URL uses this script app yet another
thing that's associated with Apps Script
which is the script itself as a service
and you can get the URL of the script
app as a web app and return this saying
this is the URL and then append some
parameters to it saying here's your name
here's your email address and here's
your row and you notice I use this
encode URI component which is just part
of JavaScript because this is a
JavaScript environment so you can just
call JavaScript functions and make them
work and there's various other bits and
generate and the a URL such as whether
or not they're actually signing it or
just viewing the NDA so how do you get
Apps Script to act as a web app it's
pretty simple you publish it by clicking
this publish button deploy as web app
and then here you see do you want to
deploy it as a web app and it gives you
the URL and gives you some information
of the version who it's going to execute
as who can access the app and in order
to serve it you just create a function
called do get and app scripts will
automatically run this function when
someone hits the HTTP request at that
URL and we can get parameters from it
such as the URL parameters we get the
name the email parameter the row
parameter and the signed parameter and
we just do some basic validation here
saying whether or not if the request
didn't have any of these fields we say
sorry we could
verify your employment but if they did
have those fields then we want to hook
into the spreadsheet a bit more so if
you remember back at the top of the
example we use a spreadsheet app get
active spreadsheet because the
spreadsheet was associated with the with
the script since you were running the
script from the spreadsheet in this
scenario you're not running the script
from the spreadsheet so you can't say
get active spreadsheet but you can just
load an arbitrary spreadsheet with that
spreadsheet ID and then we say give me
the sheet by name of the employee
tracking sheet and we get the row that
the employee said that they were at from
the URL so in this scenario here we're
not using great security because we just
put an arbitrary name an arbitrary row
and someone could theoretically change
their row number and just troll through
and try to figure out who you're hiring
what row they're on in a better example
you could imagine that you could
generate a random number
put that random number and your
spreadsheet put it in the URL and all of
those things have to match up but for
demo purposes this is a little more
straightforward and easier to walk
through but so here we get the values of
the data in that range and verify that
the name they gave us in the URL matches
the name and the spreadsheet at that row
and if it doesn't we say sorry we
couldn't verify things if they've
already signed the NDA then we just say
you've already signed it no more to do
but if they haven't signed it and this
is the request to do the signing you
said click here to sign it and they
clicked it to sign it then we update the
spreadsheet we get the row the column
that is the signing and say yes you
signed it and you can see back in the
employment that yes they're signed and
some other people have signed it and we
spit back some HTML saying thanks for
signing the NDA if this is not the
signing if this is serving of the NDA
then we generate a URL for actually
signing it and create some HTML put
output saying here's an NDA click here
to verify it that's it it's less than
200 lines it's about 167 lines and a
full workflow of how you can automate
with forums sheets stocks create
templates customize things our serve app
script as a web app and do all of these
things that make life lot simpler and
easier using app script
and if you can go back to the
presentation please and that's it for me
I'm gonna Maurice is gonna continue for
the rest of it for his demo thank you
all right so another common process we
hear a lot about is reporting so this is
a sales rep named Jane and it's time for
at the end of the quarter is approaching
and it's time for her to prep her corely
business review so she needs to load up
the data on all her accounts she wants
to get it into sheets she needs to do
some analysis and then finally package
it together into a nice presentation she
can give to her team and to her
leadership now with it without any kind
of automation this would be really
tedious
she'd have to take up the data she'd
have to find the presentation she used
last time she even have to copy paste
the data from her new her new data on to
the old slides and it's really tedious
you can make mistakes you can copy/paste
the wrong numbers and at the end of the
day it can look really bad if you make a
mistake these mistakes are not easy to
catch
so using Apps Script and the G suite
REST API is we can make this process a
lot easier
we have a Google sheets REST API that
was designed to make it really easy to
import data from external data sources
or third-party systems into Google
sheets last fall we also launched our
first-ever API for Google slides so you
can take the data in sheets or another
third-party system and make a
nice-looking slide presentation with
some simple code so let's walk through
how we can use these dressed a POS
together to make change job a lot easier
all right so the first step is to get
the raw data into Google sheets now once
it's there chain can use the great
analysis features of sheets such as
Explorer or all the all the functions
that are come built-in to understand the
data figure out what trends she wants to
highlight and visualize it you know in a
good-looking chart for example so how do
we get the data there several large
enterprise partners have already
integrated with the sheets API and if
you use some of these tools you know you
can take advantage of that and get the
data into sheet very easily so earlier
in the conference for example we
announced that
Salesforce launched a new sheets
integration where you can import your
opportunities from Salesforce straight
into sheets and update industries and
it'll sync back and forth between
Salesforce and sheets so if you're a
Salesforce user you can use that and get
your data into sheets very easily so
let's say that's not the case let's say
you have a data and you have some data
an internal service an on-premises
database
something where you kind of are on your
own
thankfully these api's are pretty easy
to work with you can write a quick
program using the sheets API and take
that data from your on-prem database and
put it directly into sheets so let's
take a look at what this code how this
code works
can we switch to the demo please all
right so here we are this is a Python
script I wrote I won't go through all of
it in detail and the bulk of it I copied
from the Google sheets API Python
QuickStart and it take has all this
boilerplate code in the beginning that
takes care of initializing the client
libraries going through OAuth in ocation
and you know making sure that the the
user gives consent for this app to edit
their spreadsheets so this is
boilerplate you can get from our
developer website I won't talk about the
bulk of that so here is the core of our
our script so the first thing we do is
we have to get the data that we want to
put into sheets and here I have a simple
sequel Lite database that's running on
my laptop I have two tables customers
and orders and I'm using some sequel to
join them together and get the data out
that I need so sequel Lite works great
for demo but this could be anything this
could be a big data warehouse this could
be a non-prime Oracle database this
could be an internal ordering service
that you need to call over HTTP this
could really be anything you know just
plug it into whatever you need to get
the data from so now let's go to the
sheet specific parts of the script so in
this main method I just I call this load
data function
gets the data from from the database I
add a header row to the data we get so
that it's easier for human to work with
afterwards and then I start calling the
sheets API so the first thing I do is I
call the spreadsheets create method
which creates an empty spreadsheet in
Google sheets here I'm giving it the
title imported from DB on date so that
it's easy to pick out from your drive
leader and then after that I take the
data that we got from the database and
turn it into the requests that we
eventually need to send the sheets to
get the data there so I do that with the
spreadsheets value update function and
for that I give it the spreadsheet ID
where in the spreadsheet I want to I
want this data to end up so the range a
1 just the top left beginning of the
spreadsheet I tell sheets that I wanted
to treat this data as user entered so
it'll automatically it'll behave as if
you typed this data by hand so it'll
understand that the things that look
like dates are dates the things that
look like numbers or numbers and again
we'll make this sheet easier to work
with at the end I also tell sheets that
my data is formatted in rows just
because we read this from a sequel
database it's naturally in rows it's
easier to import but if your data
happens to be shaped in columns you can
say columns here and sheets will do the
right thing so in a pretty quick script
you know I think I have like 30 lines of
actual sheets code we can get data from
you know of any data source practically
that this script can talk to you on to
Google sheets so let's give that a quick
run so it's just a Python script I hit
enter and there we are so it outputted
the URL of the spreadsheet I can load
here
and I can open it up and here's the data
from this from the database so I have
the customers the name of each customer
and each row is an order that that
customer placed so how many items in
their order the total dollar amounts and
what date the order was placed on so
based on this Jane can get started she
can you know do some analysis use some
functions and kind of get her work done
all right back to the slides okay so the
day isn't sheets and Jane can get to
work doing the analysis so the next step
is to make this into a good-looking
presentation she can give her team so
for this we'll use the Google slides API
and we'll call it from Apps Script so
she can work with the spreadsheet she's
working on and with the slides at the
same time so using those things together
I mean a few clicks we can get a good
looking presentation so back to the demo
please alright great so let's say Jane
did her analysis and this is what she
came up with she has a pivot table with
her the top 15 customers she works with
the in their sales per quarter for the
past year sorted by their q4 sales
she also has a chart that's a little
squished on the display but demonstrate
how demonstrates how these the sales per
customer has changed throughout the year
and some other configuration data that
we need to get the slides ready so you
know what year we care about a quarter
her name things that aren't necessarily
in the data but end up in the final
presentation so there are a couple ways
you can trigger Apps scripts from Google
sheets earlier Sam showed you that we
can add a custom menu item where you
could you know go to the menu click
click and it'll run an app an affricate
function for you here I created a button
because I think big buttons are fun to
push so if we click generate slides now
this is running my script and taking the
data from the spreadsheet combining it
with a template that we created and in a
few moments we'll have a nice finished
slide back so here's the link to the
presentation that we created and this is
what we end up with all right so this is
a simple coyly business for you review
presentation it has the title slide with
the quarter we're reporting on the year
it has Jane's name we have an executive
summary slide that has the chart we came
up with it has the total revenue for the
quarter how much we grew compared to our
goal we have a table describing the top
five customers and their quarter four
sales we have a slide with the big
ambitious goal to grow 12% next quarter
and finally we have another slide that
has a link to the spreadsheet so that if
you send this if you send this
presentation around the people looking
at it can dive into the same data you
worked on and you know either learn more
about it or double check your work okay
so let's walk through what well the code
that powers that big button so there's a
lot that goes into creating a slide
presentation so like for example here we
had to you know we kind of chose a theme
we have to make sure the colors are on
brand sometimes you want to use some
custom logos so you know instead of
writing code to define all these things
it tends to be a lot easier to work with
the template presentation so this is the
template that we used for this example
it has the five slides we'll end up with
at the end and we're using some
variables in curly braces that we'll use
some replacements to get the data from
the sheet and into the presentation so
here we have like the quarter label the
year the name on the executive summary
we have the little variables for the
total sales the direction and we have a
rectangle that we'll use to replace the
chart into that spot we have the table
that the end has the top five customers
we have the slide for our goal and we
have a slide that we'll use to link to
the source data so if you notice the the
variables already have styling on them
so instead of having to specify all the
styles by hand
in code you can make your slides you
know pretty close to what they'll end up
looking like at the end you put the
styling on the variables and the slides
API will keep that styling when you do
the replacements okay so let's look at
the code and that creates the slides so
the bulk of the work happens in this
export to slides function this is the
function that I'm calling when you click
the big button on the spreadsheet and
the first thing we do is tell the user
hey we're working on it you know we set
some text on the ranges and we flush the
changes out to the spreadsheet so that
users know that we're making progress
the next thing we do is that we've
grabbed the data out of the spreadsheet
that we need Sam kind of went through
how this works
you basically use spreadsheet app to
pick out ranges and you can get the
displayable values out of those ranges
so I'm not going to cover that in detail
since we've already kind of seen it the
next step is that we use the drive app
then that's one of the built-in
libraries inside of Apps Script and that
represents your Google Drive so we have
the ID of this template heart this is
the ID from the URL and we haven't coded
into our script so we tell drive get me
this file make me a copy please give it
this title so this we made a copy of the
template and then we'll use the slides
API to modify that template to produce
the final presentation alright so how do
we talk to slides from Apps Script so
here we're going to use what's called
the sli's advanced service so an
advanced service is a thin wrapper
around a Google REST API that's
available through Apps Script there's a
there's a pretty large list of advanced
Google services you can go to resources
google advanced services and here's kind
of the big list
of the ones that are available you see I
have the slides API and it's turned on
and a lot of these things are there it's
kind of a lower level API you get kind
of the full power of the REST API so it
ends up looking a little different than
the built-ins like start cheetah for
example that was simpler but here you
get a lot more power oh I should mention
that the
slides advance service launched on
Tuesday I actually turned it on while I
was on the flight over here from New
York alright so let's get to the slides
specific parts of this so the slides
REST API works using a batch update
model you basically assemble a list of
requests and you tell sli's please do
this please do that pleased with that
you send the big batch over the slides
API and all those requests get executed
in order in an atomic fashion so the
rest of the script basically goes
through all the things that we want to
do to the presentation we assemble this
big list and slice requests which is
just a JavaScript array and then we call
the presentations batch update method to
actually execute those changes so I'll
go through what the the steps are in the
little detail so the first thing we do
is that we call this replace alt text
method so earlier we took the data out
of the spreadsheet and we create we
added it to this data object it's just a
key value of the things we want to
replace in the in the template with the
data we want to replace it with so the
request for that looks pretty simple you
know we have we look at all the keys in
the data map we create a little object
that's the replace all text request we
say slides please take all of the text
that matches text and replace it with
this replace text so this will go
through all of your slides and put the
the data in for all those variables we
had in the template the next thing we do
is that we call this replace shape with
chart API so if you remember in the
template we had a big rectangle on the
second slide that had the text YTD chart
and we'll use that as the location of
where the chart will end up so instead
of having to mess with you know I want
the slide to be here and you don't have
to nudge it a little while oh sorry
instead of messing with the chart and
saying I want this chart to be here and
like fidgeting with where to position it
you can put a shape in your template and
then you can say you can position it
where you want you can see it in context
and you use replaced shape with chart
actually put the chart in that place so
the request for that is pretty simple
you say I want I want to replace the
shape that contains this text which is
just YTD chart in our case we tell it
the spreadsheet to grab the chart from
which is just the active spreadsheet
this script is being run from we give it
the idea of the chart and we tell it we
want this chart to be linked so what I
what I mean by linked is that slides
will remember that this chart came from
this spreadsheet so that if the
underlying data in spreadsheets changes
there will be an update button in slides
that you can click and it'll refresh the
chart automatically so that way your
data is always up-to-date there's also
there's also an API on the slides API to
call refresh on a chart for you so if
you're working with both the sheets API
and the sli's API you can change some
data in sheets and then tell slides hey
there's a new chart please pick it up so
the final thing we do is that we we add
a link at the from the last slide we add
a link to the source data so people can
take a look at the underlying data that
went into the presentation
so the first API is that we worked with
they they worked out kind of like in a
find and replace manner so we just kind
of gave them the the text in a shape and
the API kind of found it and did the
right thing some of our other API is our
object ID based so I have to give slides
the ID of the object that contains the
text that we want to add a link to so to
do that we call the presentations get
API right here and we fetched the the
presentation from slides we pick out the
final slide and then we iterate through
all
the elements on that slide so we know
that slide we created it it's a title
and body slide so it has two shapes on
it the box for the title and a box for
the body and I inter ate through the two
the two shapes on there and I find the
one that is the body placeholder so we
know that's the one that has the text
that we want to liquefy so we passed the
object ID of that shape into this update
link function alright so update link is
is a is a function that updates the
textile of that box to add a link style
to it so we do links links and slides or
textiles if you wanted to do other
textile changes like you want to make
the font different you want to make it
bold or italics you would do it in much
similar way using update textile okay so
that's all the requests that that we
needed to make the slides look the way
we want so we replaced all our variables
we added the chart and then we add the
we added the link to the source data so
finally we call batch update and then we
tell the user we generated your slides
here's when we did it and we add the URL
to the presentation back to the sheet so
in all it's probably a hundred hundred
and seventy four lines of code including
the sheet stuff I didn't cover but with
that we created a good-looking
presentation using the data in the
spreadsheet using Apps Script back to
the slides please alright so using these
API s and G sweet Jane saved several
hours of her time she avoided having to
do all this manual copy/paste and now
she's ready to give this presentation to
leadership so you know we'll all that
save time she could get to work meeting
her next quarter cools or she could go
outside and you know enjoy the sunshine
a little bit so we broke up the steps
here to kind of demonstrate what your
options are but really you could
automate this a lot further so for
example you could have the import to
sheet script run automatically every
quarter you can have it you can say like
once the data is there you can say
an email to Jane saying like hey your
data is ready you know please go take a
look and get started you kid
if you wanted to you could skip sheets
altogether and have your program that
queries the database do the analysis for
you and then it goes straight to slides
because slides is also REST API that you
can call from a third-party tool so in
in summary with some creativity and just
kind of looking around I think you can
find a lot of workflows in your
enterprise that can be automated with
Apps Script and the G suite API is
similar to the ones we've seen today and
you know these are small automations
these are things that you can write in
an afternoon you can write it in a
couple of days but even though they're
small you can you know the savings kind
of add up you know if you do the same
thing for every hiring manager for every
party organizer for every sales rep in
your company the dollar savings just
multiply and overall can make a big
impact
so the demos we did show you they do
require some coding it's pretty simple
you know it's just most of it is just
JavaScript you can we showed some Python
code today there's also pretty simple to
write and those libraries are available
in pretty much any major language so it
does require some coding it's kind of
it's simple it's within the reach of
power users and IT professionals but
it's not for everybody yet so if you're
looking for a low code way to do these
kind of automations there's a G suite
product called app maker that's
currently in early access and that
provides a drag-and-drop UI that lets
you create apps without really doing
much code so if you're interested in lat
you can request access to app maker at
developers.google.com/live maker and
they also have a showcase space at
Moscone through the end of the
conference if you find them you can
learn a lot more about how that works so
another good resource for learning about
these automations is the transformation
gallery it's a gallery that lists
several real world use cases of the G
suite api's and you know and not even
just the API switch the applications
themselves and how you can use them
together to kind of transform your
business so a lot of them come with
customer stories and
you know so you can see what the real
business impact was of deploying these
integrations in real life you can check
it out at transformation gallery dot
with Google com
alright so wrapping up Apps Script is a
lightweight tool that lets power users
IT professionals write simple JavaScript
to automate actions on top of many
Google services so today we showed you
how to script with Doc's who is slides
with sheets with Gmail with Drive but
Africa supports many other Google
services that we didn't cover today so
for example there's a library for
calendar for translate for YouTube for
maps and there's also that list of
advanced services that give you more
power for interface interfaces that are
easy to use to call Google REST API s so
in general it's easy to learn it runs in
the cloud and it's available to you as
part of your dispute subscription it is
part of the glue that helps make G suite
into a true suite of apps that work
together so they're also REST API s for
sheets and slides that make integration
with third-party data sources easy so
they provide simple ways to get your
data into G suite or you can collaborate
on it you can script it using Apps
Script or you can present it to others
so using Apps Script and our REST API S
you can automate many of the tedious
processes in your business save time and
money and let folks create focus on
creating value and instead of busy work
alright so to learn more about the
things we covered today you can check
out our developer websites for Apps
Script sheets and slides and of the URLs
on the screen right now there's a lot of
documentation available and there are
plenty of samples to help you get
started
[Music]
[Music]